each time she starts work is a moment of
validation for Victoria kikoi
she's Ukraine's first female train
co-driver
until recently sexist regulations banned
women from the job it was considered
risky to their reproductive health
now in the war it really is dangerous
for everyone on the trains
it's hard mentally and physically
because you very often hear the air raid
siren
I've even seen when missiles head
we try to suppress these emotions and
continue our work because it's not just
about our lives
the lives of the passengers sitting
behind us also depend on us
Victoria had to try many times before
she could even study for her dream job
I was applying to many universities and
colleges and asking if they could teach
me
and everyone said the same thing
no you're a woman
that was it so my name is
then one school said they did not have
the right to refuse me but they could
not promise that I would ever work in
this professional
but by the time she'd graduated the old
Soviet era ban on women doing certain
jobs had been dropped
Victorious started as a co-driver a few
months before Russia invaded in February
attention passengers our destination is
ribinka station time of departure from
kievas 1827
there is a lot to do update log books
check the speed of the Train the signals
the electrical contact line and speak to
passengers
and if something were to happen to the
driver she'd have to take over
at the beginning men treated me
suspiciously because they didn't believe
that we can do the same jobs that they
can
and women also didn't think that in our
patriarchal society
we could take on such positions
Ukraine's women are becoming more
visible everywhere
an expert on General Studies says the
necessities of War are changing Society
it's an interconnected process meaning
that women who are on the front line
become role models for civilian women
but also those women in the military
they want to see examples of women in
civilian professions they want examples
of women in traditionally male
professions outside of the military
Elena also wants to be part of that
process she graduated in economics but
two years ago decided to join the Army
as well and is now on active duty
she served in the Kiev region at the
start of the war when the Russians tried
to invade the capital
I set up checkpoints prepared Molotov
cocktails helped order medicine and
helped elderly people it was a mixture
of both military and civilian tasks she
says now even though the Russians are
further away her current job is much
more difficult my name was but we talked
to parents whose child has died and we
organized the funerals I'd rather be at
checkpoints than speaking with the
parents of dead soldiers
she says she feels it's important for
women to serve in the military to break
gender cliches but she says civilian
women who want to volunteer are being
turned away while men are taken on
I'll actually if you just show up at a
conscription office and tell them that
you want to serve no one will take you
if you have no experience they simply
won't believe in you it's probably part
of the skeptical attitude towards women
[Music]
back on the train it's late Victoria's
shift will be at least 12 hours today
[Music]
trains have become a vital form of
Transport in this war and there is never
enough staff nobody here cares whether
it's a man or a woman in charge
it doesn't make any difference at all
it's the same to me if it's a man or a
woman as long as they can do the job
there's nothing wrong with a woman
driving the train this is just work
is work
Victoria says she will still need to
push hard to make it from the co-driver
to driver
that top job is still done by a man
it hasn't completely changed yet
we still need a lot more time
we need to raise a new generation a
Young Generation with the idea that
women have the same rights as men
Victoria is pushing through the unknown
but she says there is a brighter future
for Ukrainian women
one day she will become a train driver